[Music]
on this wednesday night
ready set vaccinate how prepared are
provinces to immunize people
alberta has actually done a real service
for the country by being a poster child
for how to do it wrong
the failures so far and the improvements
already made
the prime minister's new admission who
knew what about the allegations of
misconduct
against canada's former top soldiers
catalytic converters are hot commodities
what's driving thieves to steal this
vital vehicle part
plus tired of the pandemic totally not
doing the zoom happy hours anymore
or drive by birthdays one man's mission
to cheer people up
around the world
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the ramp up of canada's
kovit 19 vaccine rollout
after a rocky start in some regions
governments are promising
faster and smoother operations as more
vaccine doses arrive and
mass vaccination clinics get underway
four vaccines are now approved for use
in canada but there is still no timeline
for when the first shipments of the
single-dose johnson and johnson vaccine
will arrive
the federal vaccine task force says 8
million doses of the other approved
vaccines will arrive
by the end of this month canada is
getting
ready uh to go into the ramp-up phase
after a steep increase in vaccine
availability the provinces have assured
us
that they're in a very good position to
scale up
as of tonight more than 2.6 million
canadians have received at least one
dose of a covid19 vaccine
that works out to roughly 5.4 percent of
the population
the rules around who is eligible for a
shot and how to book appointments
depends on where you live
there is a patchwork of phone and online
booking systems in place across canada
and not all of them are working smoothly
heather urex west has tonight's top
story on the problems
and whether the provinces are prepared
to handle more doses two weeks ago the
frustration was
palpable it is 2021 they knew 230 000
people were going to be
applying on february 24th alberta's
online and telephone booking systems
were quickly overwhelmed
on monday bc residents trying to use the
province's telephone booking system
felt similar pain i was cut off at three
hours
so i just got the dial tone again i know
there almost every system that's gone
live across the country across the world
in fact does that challenge us
undoubtedly we will have some ontario's
online booking platform is set to launch
monday as that province pushes towards
getting
two million people vaccinated by the end
of the month
but the rollout won't rely on public
health clinics alone
as of friday over 325
pharmacies will begin offering the
astrazeneca vaccine to ontarians
bringing pharmacies into the vaccine
rollout plan has helped alberta improve
its system too
it's also added call center capacity and
upgraded its online platform
and appointments for the astrazeneca
vaccine will only be available
for a limited number of people every day
as we will only receive fifty eight
thousand
five hundred doses of astrazeneca this
week
we cannot book everyone at once as there
are approximately four hundred thousand
albertans in that age group
this is why we will begin opening
bookings based on the year
you were born it's made for a smoother
process this time around
with far fewer complaints i think
alberta has actually done a real service
for the country
by being a poster child for how to do it
wrong now they fixed it and hopefully
other provinces will learn
because the rollout has really only just
begun
heather urex west global news calgary bc
is taking a new targeted approach with
its vaccine rollout to try to get cases
in a northern
community under control starting next
monday a vaccination spree will get
underway in
the prince rupert region the goal is to
get everyone who is eligible
vaccinated by april 1st the port city
near the alaska border is struggling
with a stubbornly high positivity rate
public health officials hope
accelerating the vaccine rollout
will help the ontario government says it
is considering sending more vaccines to
thunder bay where
case numbers are also rising fast in the
span of a month the number of confirmed
cobit 19 cases per capita in thunder bay
has more than quadrupled the region's
top doctor says the virus is
essentially everywhere in the community
there is no sense in sugar coating it
things are not looking very good right
now we are in the worst
situation we have ever experienced here
so far
in this pandemic the ontario government
says it is sending more people
to the region to help track cases and
contain the spread
and in toronto a temporary field
hospital is being set up outside
sunnybrook hospital
in preparation for a possible third wave
the 84 bed facility is being set up in a
parking lot
it's split into pods able to hold eight
to ten patients each
the field hospital is equipped with
medical supplies including ventilators
and portable x-ray machines
it's expected to be used for patients
awaiting placement in other health
centers
as well as recovering patients not in
need of acute care
the facility is expected to be up and
running next month
a big part of the concern around kovid
19 is the spread of those more
contagious
variants there are now over 2600
confirmed cases of the variance of
concern in canada
the one first detected in the uk
accounts for the bulk of those cases
followed by the variant first discovered
in south africa
and there are now 31 known cases of the
variant first detected
in brazil the situation in brazil is
grim it set a record today for deaths
from covid19
more than 2 000 people died in a single
day
brazil has now overtaken the u.s as the
country with the most
daily covid19 cases and deaths in the
world
every corner of that country is affected
and the highly contagious p1 variant is
driving the spread
as crystal gomencing reports hospitals
and morgues
are being pushed to the brink hospital
beds are at a premium in sao paulo even
this emergency
field hospital is full
with hospitals running out of space for
the sick and dying the state for the
third time this month
announced additional beds this time it's
338.
the governor says today we don't have
any reason to celebrate
if anything it's opposite
this week people in the country have
experienced a record number of
single day deaths brazil has been
ravaged by the pandemic with the second
highest death toll in the worlds
pamela gabriela orcozo lost her father
to covid19
academy every minute a family member is
lost she says
this is not normal this cannot be
trivialized
the p1 variant is a critical factor
the strain is believed to be different
enough from the original virus that
reinfections are occurring
and it seems to be more contagious the
rapid spread
in brazil puts everyone at risk the more
people are infected
the greater the chance the virus will
mutate
possibly into something more
transmissible or into something current
vaccines
can't protect against vaccinations
are underway in brazil but supplies are
limited
and the rollout poorly planned last week
a line stretched seven kilometers from a
vaccination site in rio de janeiro
people were irate that loved ones over
60
were forced to stand in line for hours
christopher manson global news london
there are new revelations tonight about
sexual misconduct within the canadian
armed forces
a recently released document shows the
number of reported
incidents is on the rise it could be a
sign more victims now feel comfortable
coming forward
and as michael couture explains the
problem may be more extensive and more
well known than some in authority
are willing to admit my office was aware
of the minister's direction to the
ombudsman
for the first time the prime minister
admitted that back in 2018
someone in his office knew the defense
minister was dealing with allegations
facing the country's former top soldier
previously the prime minister's office
repeatedly told global news they had no
knowledge of the allegations
former military ombudsman gary walborn
told a parliamentary committee
he tried to show evidence related to the
allegations
to defense minister harjit sajin but he
was instead directed
to the privy council office trudeau
maintains he and his office
only knew about the process nothing more
but my office and i learned of the
details
of the allegation through news reporting
over the past months
still knowing there were allegations
about former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance trudeau and his
office
gave vance a raise in 2019.
it comes as documents show an increase
in the number of reported incidents of
sexual misconduct in the military
over the last two years there were 256
in 2018-19 and then it jumped
to 356 the following year
a 39 percent increase i think we are
only aware the tip of the iceberg
only because most people don't report it
retired colonel michelle drapeau runs
the only military law office in canada
he says the system of reporting
misconduct is broken because it's dealt
with
by the military leaving victims with no
other option
there are growing calls for an
independent investigative body with an
extra level
of accountability there's that longer
process of cultural change which also
deserves
an external oversight mechanism so that
change is monitored and there is some
system
of accountability in place in response
to questions about reducing barriers to
reporting complaints of sexual
misconduct in the military
a spokesperson for the department said
important steps have been taken but they
acknowledge
there is more work to be done donna
michael couture in ottawa thanks the
federal government announced today it
has hit a milestone bringing clean water
to indigenous communities but wouldn't
commit
for on a timeline for lifting the
remaining long-term drinking water
advisories on first nations reserves
the trudeau government was elected in
2015 on a promise to eliminate all
drinking water advisories by this year
the government will miss that target but
indigenous services minister mark miller
says 101 drinking water advisories have
been lifted since 2015
and work is underway to lift 58 others
in 38
different communities we're in it for
the long term
the work doesn't stop once advisories
are lifted
we're also making investments in
expanding water infrastructure and
operations
in maintenance and training programs to
ensure we never find ourselves
in this situation again ottawa has set
aside 1.5 billion dollars to complete
the work
ontario has the most drinking water
advisories 26
manitoba saskatchewan and bc also have
advisories
there is also a new federal website to
track progress on
eliminating those remaining advisories
the military reservist who stormed the
gates at rideau hall in ottawa last year
while armed has been sentenced to jail
corey huron has been given a six-year
sentence and with credit for time served
he will spend
five years behind bars he's also banned
from owning any firearms
in july the 46 year old rammed his truck
into a gate at rideau hall
he then headed on foot toward the prime
minister's home armed with several
weapons
after a lengthy standoff he was arrested
hawaii's state of emergency
coming up the disaster after record
rainfall plus
a precious car part targeted how to put
the brakes
on thieves
these streets on the hawaiian island of
maui turned into raging rivers after
some of the heaviest rainfall in more
than a quarter century
parts of hawaii recorded half a month's
worth rain in a single day
there's extensive damage to homes and
roads and a state of emergency has been
declared
the weather system is expected to remain
over the islands through tomorrow and
possibly into the weekend police in many
countries are dealing with a rash of
thefts from vehicles
it's not what's inside them that's being
targeted but what's underneath
catalytic converters reduce emissions
from gas-powered engines
and they contain tiny amounts of
extremely precious metals
so precious they're worth more than gold
eric sorenson explains what that has led
to
the thieves work quickly in cities all
over the country
they like bigger vehicles they're easier
to get under at this heating business in
guelph ontario they made off with seven
catalytic converters in one night our
service tech started to start up the
trucks
the next thing you know all the trucks
were just making so much noise there was
no exhaust systems on them
this is what they're taking that's the
catalytic converter it costs
thousands to replace its value is first
to the environment
traditional engines burn fuel that
produce harmful fumes like carbon
monoxide and nitrous
oxide the catalytic converter transforms
much of it to less harmful
carbon dioxide nitrogen and water the
catalyst
is a metallic core made of precious
metals like platinum
rhodium and palladium just a few grams
but the value twelve years ago palladium
was worth about two hundred dollars an
ounce u.s
gold by comparison was eleven hundred
and while it has risen to around
seventeen hundred dollars
palladium has rocketed to more than
twenty three hundred dollars an ounce
more valuable than gold the nuts are on
the ground here
and it's accessible under millions of
vehicles that's all you have to pop one
end off
a dozen trucks at this dodge dealership
in langley bc were stripped of their
converters
as were several buses at this non-profit
children's agency in calgary
one scrap yard dealer suggests there's a
black market for unscrupulous operators
when the prices go up the theft goes up
thousands of converters are being ripped
off insurers are looking for ways that
manufacturers can embed
identification on the devices because
right now these
units aren't marked in any way so if
it's marked
and traceable back it'll hopefully
diminish their ability to get rid of
some of this product
police advise where possible park
vehicles inside or in well-lit
areas or where there are cameras because
with prices as high as they are for
precious metals
even a few grams from several converters
can be a lucrative night's work for
thieves
eric sorensen global news toronto
caring for health care workers still
ahead the burnout behind canada's
pandemic front line
as we approach what appears to be a
semblance of normal life there will be a
need to take stock of what's been lost
in the last year
including the toll on those who care for
covet 19 patients
the physical and psychological strain
has left some deep wounds
and will take time to heal tonight karen
lieberman
has some of their stories
when it became clear there was a need
for help on the front lines
kelly cray answered the call we're right
there
at the greatest risks as a respiratory
therapist cray is a crucial part of the
fight against covid19
helping patients to breathe and often
providing comfort as they take their
final breaths
we see them at their worst and we hope
we get them through
through it with as minimal
amount of casualties as possible she
says it's been an emotional roller
coaster
certainly she's not alone for the ride
the pandemic has presented an
unprecedented challenge
not just for society but for those
providing the public health response
as health care workers just all very
burnt out from the mental burden the
emotional burden
being on the front line caring for
patients with covid19
and navigating a year-long global health
crisis
adds even more pressure to an already
high stress job
emergency physician shasma mathani has
had to balance the needs of her
patients with the demands of her young
family
recently she gave up a shift because she
needed a mental health break
i didn't have the ability or the
resiliency to bounce back the way that i
had before the pandemic dr jillian
horton just published a book about her
own struggle with burnout
we are all perfectly fine ask the
question
when we need help we count on doctors
but what happens
when doctors fall apart physicians are
really
bad for this in terms of how we talk to
one another how we inquire about how our
colleagues are
are doing we we don't have a culture
where we talk a lot about the times when
we're not doing
fine that can be especially problematic
because burnout
may be easily hidden behind the mask so
we're burying a huge burden of caring
and i think it's compounded by
the fact that we're working longer we're
working more dr julianne irving
specializes in physician wellness and is
getting referrals from doctors
needing support and feeling exhausted
people might not have full-blown ptsd
but are certainly having some of the
symptoms
so not sleeping as well feeling
chronically anxious having difficulty
turning their fight or flight system off
if anyone understands trauma it's kelly
cray
what the public sees through the camera
is not necessarily what goes on here is
is
tiring frustrating
and that takes a toll karen lieberman
global news toronto
karen looks at how health care workers
are finding creative ways to cope
with burnout
staying hopeful at home next the
canadian who just keeps dancing
you're watching global national
[Music]
politicians sometimes dodge reporters
questions but
thailand's prime minister took it to a
new level during a news conference he
was asked about a possible cabinet
shuffle
he not only refused to answer the he
then sprayed the front row of reporters
with sanitizer the quick-tempered former
army commander who overthrew the elected
government in thailand in 2014
is known for his impulsive behavior
well lots of people are short-tempered
and tired these days and it's no wonder
after a year of living through the
pandemic
of course it is wise to look for the
positives and some of us have embraced
spending time at home but
let's face it puzzles baking and binge
watching can only keep you interested
for so long
mike trolley examines the ups and downs
of the last year
remember the shock of that first
lockdown we went from
bustling cities to eerie quiet overnight
but we adapted even embraced the
isolation by spending more time doing
family activities
we took up hobbies like baking so many
goodies big and small
and the fails they were even better but
as the weather warmed up the lustre of
the virtual
began to fade i just can't be on another
zoom call
i almost refuse i'm like i'm over it i'm
over zoom
and that was the beginning of the slump
i'm not a cat by winter it was on full
display as participation in virtual or
distance events
bottomed out definitely totally not
doing the zoom happy hours anymore
or drive by birthdays you can't see it
in one bit and
in a in a bachelor watching tv all the
time
you have a cigarette then you end up
smoking all cigarettes and it's not good
for you
but the slump was more than frustration
and annoyance
antidepressant prescriptions went up 20
according to some insurance companies
and even the most upbeat people admitted
to feeling down
yeah i i have my moments of reflections
too
during my day time and when that happens
dradeep pander
dances over the last year
millions of people have watched gurdeep
do traditional bangla dances
in the wilderness near his yukon cottage
and he's become
so popular he no longer does it work for
the government
like so many letters from all over
the world right now these are not just
letters i received yesterday
if he ever has a day when he feels a
little down he recalls messages like the
one he received from a girl immobilized
in a hospital bed
and i watch your videos and i dance
i do little dancing in the bed
it was such a powerful message i watched
the video i could oh my god it's
it's a really huge yeah it's huge
and hopefully all of this along with the
slump is over soon
mike drolite global news toronto and
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is hopetown on the
gaspe peninsula in quebec
please email us a picture of your canada
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye